le doctor à rousseau qui est également
hématologue bonjour à vous merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur arte france
alors dans cette tribune vous dites que
pour l'instant les cohortes marseillaise
qui ont été traités par le professeur
out ne montre pas d'effets secondaires
majeurs mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
en être sûr
alors vous avez raison c'est une des
grandes difficultés concernant la
chloroquine aux deux il ya d'efficacité
d'à côté la toxicité de l'autre on la
toxicité
elle est bien connue concernant les
dropsy chloroquine depuis des années
mais c'est vrai à des 12 plus tôt plus
faibles que celles qui sont utilisées
par le professeur raoul qui utilise 600
mg alors que d'habitude c'est 200 400
donc il ya un point d'interrogation
concernant la toxicité cardiaque
principalement notamment en association
avec l'azithromycine selon ce protocole
les antilles raul disent qu'il ya des
complications cardiaques
le professeur raoul dit que ça se passe
très bien
il a il faut reconnaître traité
actuellement pratiquement 2000 patients
et si vous lisez sur son site le taux de
mortalité il ya sept malades qui sont
décédés on n'en connaît pas la cause
mais je pense comme vous il est très
important que le professeur raoul
rapporte très rapidement sur
l'expérience clinique sur ce très grand
nombre de malades pour qu'on puisse
avoir une idée non seulement de
l'efficacité chez les malades pris au
début d'infection et nous supposons
l'efficacité sur un meilleur mais aussi
sur la toxicité est il que pensez vous
de l'attitude du gouvernement des
autorités de la santé a vis-à-vis
justement du professeur out je sais pas
quelle est leur comportement je sais
quelle a été la décision qu'ils ont
prise concernant la mise à disposition
de l'hydroxyde chloroquine qui a fait
l'objet d'un décret ce décret dans sa
première version je l'avais à prouver
parce que c'était la possibilité pour
traiter des malades hospitalisés dans un
contexte qui permettait de bien
surveiller le traitement et chez des
malades qui avaient des symptômes donc
juste
une intervention thérapeutique
malheureusement le lendemain le
gouvernement est venu en arrière et a
restreint l'utilisation à des malades
graves avec défaillance respiratoire ou
défaillance d'un autre organe or on sait
très bien qu'au stade ultime de
l'affection
c'est là où il ya le moins de chance de
montrer une efficacité c'est là où j'ai
le plus de chances d'avoir une toxicité
est d'ailleurs les malades qui soit en
réanimation
les dégâts qui sont niveau des poumons
ne sont pas liés au virus lui même
ils sont liés aux aux complications
inflammatoires en relation avec le virus
donc c'est sûrement le plus mauvais
choix de réserver ce traitement pour les
malades en réanimation humains des plus
grave c'est sûrement le plus mauvais
choix donc nous pensons que lorsqu'on
traite plus tôt eh bien on a des chances
d'empêcher l'aggravation qui justifiera
une hospitalisation de réduire le nombre
de malades qui passeront en réanimation
ce qui est l'objectif du gouvernement
aplatir la courbe des malades qui en
croire et une nation évidemment diminuer
le nombre de décès mais il ya aussi un
autre intérêt qui serait en diminuant la
charge virale la durée de portage virus
on diminuerait la contagiosité des
patients et on permettrait lutter plus
efficacement contre l'épidémie en
association bien sûr au portage au port
de masques et les toques de confinement
sur ce dernier point
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire cela selon
justement dans les résultats
préliminaires des travaux du doctorat ou
alors il ya beaucoup d'arguments publier
les premiers sur venus de chine
d'ailleurs il faut pas toujours jeter au
panier ce qui vient de chine
ce qu'ils ont réalisé pour bloquer leur
épidémie en particulier dans les grandes
mégapoles comme pékin et shanghai est
tout à fait exceptionnel donc ses
premiers résultats sont venues de chine
les résultats publiés par le professeur
raoul ont fait comme vous le savez
l'objet d'une grande controverse parce
que la méthodologie et ne faisait pas de
comparaison suffisante avec des sujets
témoins en particulier la deuxième
étude sur 80 malades suggéré une
diminution rapide de la charge virale et
une diminution rapide de la durée totale
d'infection puisque une semaine plus de
95 % des malades ne portait plus de
virus donc voilà il n'ya pas
malheureusement dans cette étude de
groupes contrôlent ce qui fait naître
toute la polémique
maintenant c'est un argument suffisant
me semble-t-il aux côtés de certaines
observations cliniques qui permettent de
montrer un bénéfice notamment là encore
en chine pour que dans une situation de
guerre n'ont pas d'autres possibilités
je vous le rappelle il y a des centaines
de malades qui meurent tous les jours en
france des milliers qui meurt en europe
donc il faut agir vite et dans ces
circonstances je considérais mes amis
avec moi qu'il n'y a pas de risques à
tenter ce traitement à condition bien
sûr de respecter des contre indications
de surveiller les atteintes cardiaques
éventuelle mais il n'y a pas de risques
à tenter cette option thérapeutique qui
pourra rendre de grands services
si elle est véritablement efficace le
professeur raoul tu va nous rapporter
ses résultats j'espère très rapidement
eh bien on verra si l'hypothèse qui fait
d'une efficacité meilleur avec un
traitement plus précoce basé sur la
diminution rapide de la charge virale
sera confirmée par les résultats
cliniques
je l'espère en tout cas pour les malades
et si c'était le cas il faudrait que le
gouvernement mène leur place d'une
structure des structures légères pour
des hospitalisations très courte pour
traiter un maximum de malades ça
voudrait dire augmenter très largement
le nombre de patients dépistés tous les
patients symptomatiques tous les
patients contacter les traiter ces
patients dans cette unité où
travailleraient ensemble le public et le
privé éventuellement des cardiologues
pour être sûr qu'il ya pas de problème
au début du traitement et les médecins
généralistes qu'on utilise à mon avis
pas assez dans cette crise du coc vide
et puis on attend aussi
les résultats de l'étude européenne
discovery puisque la chloroquine son
usager est inclus dans les traitements
de cette étude dont les résultats
devaient les avoir la semaine dernière
en fin de semaine on attend toujours
pourquoi selon vous ah ben je ne sais
pas effectivement j'avais un peu parier
que les résultats se ferait attendre
parce que ce sont des études lourde avec
beaucoup de malades dans différents pays
donc je suis pas tout à fait surpris
mais c'est vrai que on aimerait bien
savoir si l'un des bras est utile ou pas
j'ajoute que j'avais fait des réserves
sur le schéma de l'étude parce que il ya
un des bras ou les malades ne reçoivent
pas de traitement
mais moi personnellement ça me choque
puisqu'il s'agit de malades graves que
l'on puisse traiter quatre cinquièmes
des malades mais ne pas traiter de le
dernier 5e
les études randomisées sont très souvent
nécessaire il ya des circonstances quand
on n'a pas de solution pour le patient
ou l'absence de traitement pourrait être
critiqué enfin je termine concernant
cette étude discovery redisant que
lehman a choisi son aîné malade grave et
je répète que c'est pas dans ces
circonstances qu'on risque d'avoir le
meilleur effet de l'hydroxyte le rock
inn et peut-être d'ailleurs des
antiviraux qui sont testés merci
beaucoup
dr jean luc harousseau d'avoir répondu
en direct à nos questions je rappelle
que vous êtes hématologue ancien
président de la haute autorité de santé
merci à vous merci